I got this great idea I want to quote
spider-man and he's a teenager
so I gave him the idea and he said stand
that is the worst idea I have ever heard
if you can't learn to dream big but act
small your ideas will never be realized
just do it
just stop thinking about it just do it
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message just do it over
to you Stanley I had done the Fantastic
Four and the x-men and my publisher said
hey they're doing well do another one so
I came up with spider-man and I said to
him I got this great idea I want to
quote spider-man and he's a teenager so
I gave him the idea and he said Stan
that is the worst idea I have ever heard
he said first of all people hate spiders
you can't call it hero spider-man
secondly he said he can't be a teenager
teenagers are only sidekicks and finally
he can't have personal problems don't
you know what a superhero is so he
wouldn't let me do it one day we had a
book we were gonna kill called amazing
fight a fantasy when you're gonna do the
last issue nobody cares what you put in
it just to get it out of my system I put
spider-man in the book and we sold it
and it was a best-seller so my publisher
called me in a couple weeks later to
stand you remember that character
spider-man that you and I liked so much
why don't you do a series of it and
that's how Spidey was born dream big act
small when you've got a big idea it's
easy to make that idea bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger and see
how it's gonna change the world and see
how it's gonna have this gigantic impact
but then what happens is you need to
have a team and you need to have venture
capital you need to have partners you
need to have co-founders you
all of this stuff all of these people
all of this financing all this
infrastructure before you can ever get
started because it's such a huge amazing
idea and what ends up happening is you
don't start because it's too big because
it's too scary and so what you need to
do is yes have a big idea it's amazing
it's what's gonna keep you motivated and
ambitious and hungry and act small the
most important thing that you can do
once you've figured out what your big
idea is is to act small find a smallest
possible way to get started on your idea
and just go and do it if you can't learn
to dream big but act small your ideas
would never be realized you will die
with your ideas still within you knowing
that you could have done something
amazing but you're too afraid to just
get started just do it enact small so I
made this mistake in my first business
and it cost me forty million dollars I
made this mistake where I thought I had
to have the perfect business plan
because I thought I had this huge idea
my hand which I did but I spent so much
time planning planning planning planning
everyday at the dining room table of my
partner's apartment planning planning
planning planning planning and we ended
up having a decent business plan we made
almost the right call but it wasn't
quite the right one and a big company
came in and bought our competitors
instead of us and I lost a forty million
dollar deal we were the other table with
number two at the table and if we got
there sooner if we just stopped planning
so much and just did just got started on
it we would have maybe had more success
doesn't mean we would've for sure won
but we were late to the party and we got
to be the number two player imagine if
we were there just a little bit sooner
and so that taught me not to be
perfectionist that taught me that the
planning is important but it's not the
whole game you need to you need to plan
think big but do it's in the doing that
you start to win the five ninety five
rule five percent eighty time planning
and ninety five percent of your time
doing I never since that moment ever
since losing a forty million dollar deal
when I was twenty-one twenty-two I've
tried to stop being as much of a
perfectionist and so as an example I
started a new morning show on Instagram
where every morning at 9:00 a.m. I do a
morning show on Instagram live and on
the first one it was just me a camera
and a tripod and two chairs and had a
guest come in
and there was no lighting and the audio
was brutal I'm halfway across the room
in a pretty big room and relying on my
phone to pick up the audio and
people-watch insane Evan this is a great
idea we love the energy but we can't
understand anything you're seeing is
you're too far away like huh okay I
guess I should have a microphone right
and that would have been the thing that
I would have stressed out over I need a
microphone and your lighting I need a
guy to come in and make sure
everything's in focus I need to have the
perfect setup and have the perfect
schedule what time was the best time to
go Instagram live and all of these
things that just delay you actually
doing and most of those things don't
matter and so I just did the first one
and it felt amazing and the audio sucked
so the next day I ordered a microphone
and they had one come in and then we
kept going and that's how you win you
take that big idea this revolution idea
that's gonna change the world amazing it
keeps you motivated and what are you
gonna do right now to get started in
some small way so I'm gonna give you
three ways to do it to bust through that
perfectionist gene and just start taking
action step number one is use a no money
rule I hate spending money till I'm
making money and so use the no money
rule to look at how can I start this
thing with zero money because money
becomes the restriction because you say
well I can't start this until I have
$100 or $1,000 or $10,000 or million
dollars or whatever you're looking to
raise for your business great no money
you have to start this thing with no
money if you had to start it with no
money what would you do apply the no
money rule so I applied this to my
youtube channel when I was first filled
in my youtube channel I had a team on my
website I had a team in my business I
had I don't know eight or so people in
my company and I was making money and
was having success I'm gonna start a
YouTube channel I'm gonna apply the no
money rule I'm not gonna spend anything
until I start making some money and so
my very first videos were a combination
of one partnering with my friend mark
Drager and he made some of the early
videos for me he came in and filmed them
and edited them for me and to then meet
you soon on my own me just getting a
flip camera or a DSLR camera putting it
up on a Ledge pressing record and
filling it myself and they were brutal
and they were terrible and and it's
embarrassing looking back on those right
but that's how this channel started
that's how this channel started if I
just thought about well I need to have a
full-on production crew and a huge team
and lighting the microphone and fancy
cameras and all of this stuff I would
have never started I would not be here
it'd be ten years later I'm still
sitting on that idea how many ideas are
you sitting on how many ideas that you
think are genius you're just sitting on
and you realize holy cow I've been
sitting on this idea for 1 2 3 5 years
is because you're unwilling to act small
because you only want to go big and
that's why you're losing so apply the no
money rule to your business today step
number 2 is start Monday whenever you
got an idea we're gonna start Monday
so we're applying the no money rule
ain't when you're gonna do it we're
gonna start Monday start Monday
start Monday when Monday what are you
gonna start Monday so it was on the
flight back from LA and I decided that I
wanted to do this morning Instagram live
show and I felt myself losing momentum
because I was nervous to do it and the
further I got away from my decision I
felt like I don't need to do that try to
convince myself of why I don't need to
do that and so I got on the airplane and
started emailing everybody on my team
because doing my morning show takes up
two hours in my morning everyday I
didn't magically have that and so I
emailed everybody to say hey guys I'm
doing this new morning show we're gonna
adjust her schedules around we're gonna
make it work and then I emailed people
who would be my first guests for the
show this was Friday at around midnight
Friday at around midnight that I was on
the plane doing this and they got
response back from one of the guys on my
team and he said awesome everyone I love
this idea it's so great when do we start
Monday we start Monday we start ASAP
right maybe this rule should be start
tomorrow but start Monday like start
immediately right now just like the
apply the no money rule means you have
to figure out a way to start the
business or start your idea without any
money the start Monday means you have to
figure out a way to start on Monday
regardless right like you don't have the
resources you don't have the team you
don't have whatever you think that you
need to get started we're still going on
Monday it's happening on Monday if the
lights were totally blocked out I would
still make my first Instagram live on
Monday it has to happen Monday when
Monday when you're gonna start Monday
what if we don't Monday what if people
don't show up Monday what if we don't
have enough reason Monday Monday Monday
were starting Monday
go make it happen stop coming with
excuses and instead start Monday and
step number three is expect to suck at
the start of everything that you ever do
you should suck I just came back from a
Tony Robbins event and there was a guy
who wanted to make videos and so I said
you wanna make videos gonna be like me
awesome let's start pull out your phone
we're gonna make a video right now right
now yeah right now let's go yeah I'm
gonna be your first guest on the show
it's gonna be amazing so he went to
Facebook live in his first video is a
Facebook live of me and him at the Tony
Robbins event and you can't hear
anything because the room was super loud
and we didn't have microphones we
applied to no money rule when did we
start not Monday we started immediately
we just made it happen and we sucked
them and one of the things I told him is
wow that really sucked this is the best
because if you went live on Facebook if
you made your first video and you
crushed it if you were amazing
that means you actually should have
started five years ago that means you've
been sitting on this thing for way way
way way way too long and so if you don't
suck at the beginning that means you're
starting way too late you've been
sitting in your idea for too long so you
need to suck at the beginning expect to
suck at the beginning that's how you
start that's amazing and from there you
will learn and get better and grow and
ultimately win so dream big act small
whether you're applying to no money rule
to start Monday or expect to soccer all
three of them dream big act small use
your big dreams as motivation to push
you forward and recognize that you need
to start immediately right now with what
you have and it's going to be terrible
and as long as you make forward momentum
every single day you will win while your
friends are sitting on the couch you
still dreaming big still dreaming big
still dreaming big and never taking
action now I've got a really special
bonus clip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for
question of the day I want to know which
of the three steps resonated the most
with you are you going to apply the
money rule start Monday or expect to
suck let me know put in the comments
below
one of my biggest issues in creating
content beep that's cinematography like
film stuff or photo stuff or coming up
with a photo series or just trying to
grind out ideas for new art and content
and media a lot of my issue comes in me
not being able to get out of my own head
I think a lot about everything I think
about okay well it could look better if
I if I wait until I set up my office to
make it look a little cooler with a nice
background or maybe it'll be better when
I get that extra light I'm gonna wait
till I get the light or it could be
better if I did stop just stop
step one just do it just stop thinking
about it just do it just film just start
filming now forget about the light
forget about the couch or the setup or
the background or I don't know where to
get music from I don't know where just
forget all of that for now the only
thing you need to think about
it's just filming same thing goes for
photos I don't know what to take photos
of or I don't know how to get my photos
to look as good as this guy that I
follow on Instagram or you know how
you're gonna get there by taking
thousands of bad photos you're gonna get
better once you go through the you know
how do you take good photos you take
thousands of bad photos until you start
taking more good photos and then the
ratio starts changing and then suddenly
you've got more good photos than you
have bad photos and before you know it
people are asking you how to take good
photos but the step that is required to
get to that point is just starting to
take photos take photos of whatever
shoot what you're eating shoot your trip
to Ikea find something interesting in a
shopping mall and take photos of it hang
out with some friends shoot that just
shoot your pets your kids your anything
you just got to start just do it just
pick up a camera and start shooting
something don't wait to be asked because
nobody's going to ask
and don't wait for the perfect
conditions because they'll never be
perfect it's a little bit like having a
child if you wait until the right time
to have a child you'll die childless and
I think filmmaking is very much the same
thing you just have to take the plunge
and just start shooting something even
if it's bad you can always hide it but
you will have learned something
guys like you have come in and produced
massive hits coming essentially out of
nowhere how how is how was the game
changed with technology in music well I
mean you don't really need anything
anymore you need your computer that's
all you need you don't need any any
keyboards you don't need anything to
produce interviews if you know the
program like good quality music you know
and then obviously you're gonna have to
you know you have to know melodies and
you know if not everyone can learn that
but it's definitely made it easier for
so many people to get into this and you
know get started with it and and you
know a lot of people maybe that before
couldn't afford or didn't want to risk
buying hardware for in you know
thousands of dollars because they didn't
know if they could produce or not but
now it's like all for pretty much
nothing you can just download and it's
amazing things like GarageBand for
example exactly yeah or any of the pro
there's so many programs and you know
it's all about how you work with the
program as well so no it's it's just
amazing how how easy it is to get
started now if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon if you want more stainle
check out the top ten rules video I made
on him it's right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
years ago I used to feel somewhat
embarrassed that I was writing comics
you